Nicholas lemon author of the promised
land the great black migration and how
it changed America who is Ruby Lee
Hopkins she's the heroine of my book she
is a lady well tell you a little bit of
the story of her life this book is
called the great black migration and how
it changed America which refers to the
migration from the rural South to the
urban north but mrs.
her name is now mrs. Haynes she really
has been part of four great migrations
the way I figured she's had an
incredibly eventful life she was born in
1916 the first great migration that she
took part in was a migration of southern
rural blacks who were living in the
hills of the south kind of eking out an
existence as small farmers into the
sharecropper system which existed on big
plantations when she was a baby just
born a white labor recruiter came to the
town where she was living and talked to
her grandfather into the idea that if he
moved down to the Mississippi Delta
which is the home of fabulously rich
soil and big cotton plantations that he
would make a lot of money which wasn't
true but anyway he believed it he
carried her as a baby down to the
Mississippi Delta so that was the first
great migration and she really lived for
the first about twenty to twenty-five
years of her life in the sharecropper
system can I stop you and ask you what a
sharecropper is yes a sharecropper is a
tenant farmer who is the system is this
sharecropper is is the successor system
to slavery in the South basically the
way it works is the sharecropper lives
on a plantation does not own the land is
given a plot of land fifteen acres would
be a typical size on a very big
plantation of thousands of acres and the
deal with the farmer is
provides housing feed and seed and and
the sharecropper raises a cotton clap
and at the end of the year the crop is
ginned pick ginned Wade sold and they
split the proceeds fifty-fifty but
they're still sharecroppers in America
basically no I mean I wouldn't somebody
will come forth and say I'm still a
sharecropper but the system doesn't
really exist anymore
when did it die well it died uh mostly
in the 1940s what in the in when
Franklin Roosevelt was president there
started to be a lot of liberal pressure
against the sharecropper system for a
bunch of reasons I'll get into in a
minute it was a very unfair system and
considered rightly to be cruel and
inhumane it's a physics it's a system of
rural serfdom of the kind you don't
think of happening in twentieth-century
America two things really ended the
sharecropper system one is the invention
of various machines in this case the
mechanical cotton picker that took away
the need for hand labor in in the fields
especially in big plantations what year
did they invent the mechanical cotton
Peck
well it was invented over a long period
of time that could be a whole other book
it's sort of like the history of the
automobile it was several people
competing to be the inventor and and
working on it over a 20-year period 1944
is when the machine was reduction ready
it could be made by a factory and sold
on a mass production basis to farmers
and put in the field and used as an
aside a man named John rust is really
the father of the mechanical cotton
picker ironically John rust was a
socialist and and he believed that the
mechanical cotton picker would be used
to establish socialism in the southern
cotton fields and that the farms would
be turned over to the sharecroppers each
sharecropper would have a cotton pickin
machine and would become a kind of
yeoman farmer the exact opposite
really happened John rust died a
bankrupt and bitter man all of the labor
was kicked off the southern farms by the
cotton picker and the whole dream of
turning tenant farmers into independent
small farmers which is an update of you
know 40 acres and a mule from
reconstruction that never happened let
me go back because I interrupted you and
we got off the track first of all this
picture where I asked you more about
Ruby Haynes
weird this picture come the pictures
taken 1941 in Chicago sassy Chicago on
Easter Sunday morning heavy do you know
about the Farm Security Administration
there's a great man named Roy Stryker
who was an economist and a sort of minor
New Deal official with no photographic
training who was put in charge of a sort
of propaganda agency in the Roosevelt
administration and hired many great
photographers like Ben Sean and Walker
Evans and Dorothea Lange to travel
around the country taking pictures of
social conditions all of the famous
pictures you've seen of the Depression
were taken by his photographers this
picture was taken by Russell Lee one of
the FSA photographers and a man that I
knew in fact he died a couple years ago
how'd you find it we were looking for a
picture for the book cover and B I'm
familiar with photography in fact I
wrote an earlier book about Roy Stryker
and his subsequent photographic project
for a standard oil now Exxon in the
1940s you know whether any of these kids
back in the 40s are still alive they
would have to be still alive because I'm
just guessing they would have been born
this is 1941 these kids are born maybe
1930 so they'd be 60-ish today none of
them have come forward and said that's
me no I'm waiting for it to happen in my
whole last book involved getting
pictures like this from the 1940s and
tract
down the people in the pictures and
telling their stories so I've been
asking myself I wonder if I could find
those people it's much harder to do if
the pictures taken in a big city that if
it's taken in a small town I don't know
if I could find it but I've been sort of
hoping that one of them will come out
and say their pictures aren't in the
caption of the picture so the names
aren't you know right you were starting
to talk about Ruby
Lea Hopkins now Ruby Haynes am I correct
about that Ruby yes she's had how many
different names three Hopkins Daniel's
hates by the way she's still alive she's
still alive and lives where Clarksdale
Mississippi you started talking about
the migration where are we in that well
okay she moved to the Mississippi Delta
and lived on a succession of plantations
all through the 1920s and 1930s as a
sharecropper staying with various
relatives chiefly her mother she was
born to a teen mother who wasn't married
she almost never met her father she
didn't meet mrs. Haynes didn't meet her
father until she was about 20
she shuttled back and forth between her
mother's home in her grandfather's home
and both her mother and grandfather
themselves moved among plantations a lot
which was very typical of sharecroppers
very often show covers moved every
single year from plantation to
plantation after the sharecropper system
began to die out she moved in a sort of
second great migration into the nearest
sizable town which was Clarksdale
Mississippi one of the bigger towns in
the Delta first migration from the hills
to the Delta to be a sharecropper second
migration from the drafty unheated
sharecropper cabins on the plantations
into the town which in this case was
Clarksdale Mississippi yes and then the
third migration is to Chicago Illinois
that's the big one and did she go back
then to Clarkston she went to Chicago
she lived in Chicago for about
thirty years and then forth migration is
back to Clarksdale in 1980 how did you
find her
I found her that took a long time that
was the hardest thing in the book I've
been working on this book for about six
years and continually all through that
time with maybe six and a half by now
and and all through that time I've been
looking for someone like her to be the
main character of the book and I went I
can't tell you how many blind alleys
there were very hard to find the right
person I went through church records I
went through social welfare agency
records I've got people to take me
around in Chicago got people to take me
around in Clarksdale what were you
looking for I was looking for somebody
who had lived through X amount of
history number one you had to have that
to qualify you had to have lived as a
sharecropper and made that great
migration okay when did you decide this
is the kind of person you wanted to find
what led up to that where were you in
your head trying to you know what six
years ago whether I started off writing
about inner-city ghettos what year well
first time 1980 where were you I was a
reporter for The Washington Post and at
that time I had what I would call the
typical Washington assumptions about
ghettos which which was that everything
about ghettos is a result of federal
Social Welfare policy so if you want to
understand inner-city ghettos you should
look through the lens of federal policy
making so I did a series for the Post in
Philadelphia about a welfare mother was
about the welfare system after I
finished that I spent several months
there and after I finished it I had a
very strong feeling when we were going
around taking pictures I thought you
know it just suddenly dawned on me I've
done the wrong story the woman that I
was writing about was a migrant from
North Carolina
and really I found in interviewing her
she was much more interested in telling
the story of her migration to the north
and the evolution she had seen in her
neighborhood then she was in describing
her interaction with the welfare system
that was the real story and I I've kept
finding and interviewing her I would say
she would say now let me tell you about
growing up in North Carolina say no no
no don't talk about that talk about
welfare and it's always a bad sign for a
report or at least for the kind of work
that I do if you start to feel like
you're forcing people to talk about what
you've defined is the topic instead of
what the real topic is were you from
original New Orleans so after I did that
story I resolved to write another story
later about migration from the South
trying to understand ghettos through the
lens of the great migration and all the
changes that happened in those city
neighborhoods over the years since World
War two so so the idea was in my mind
since late 1980 when did you get your
first interest in even writing about the
poverty situation in this country I
can't tell you I just in the n8 I've
always been interested in that what was
your life like in New Orleans a million
miles away from what I write about my I
come from a family of lawyers I was
expected to be a lawyer how many kids in
the family - both of them were writers
but but we didn't know any writers or
journalists no one in our family had
ever been one and I was just I lived in
a world in which everybody was either a
lawyer a doctor basically where'd you go
to school I went to school in New
Orleans up to high school and then to
Harvard and what got you interested in
going to Harvard and what you study
there well what got me interested in
going to Harvard was that my dad went
there he was interested in my going to
Harvard I would say would be a more
accurate statement
and and what I study there is American
history and literature but I really
majored in in student newspaper but you
had to be a good student to get during
the first place to Harvard yeah I was I
wasn't a great student but I was I was I
mean I didn't go to one of these I mean
one of the advantages of growing up in
the provinces instead of Washington DC
is you do not have to be a super
achiever you know at an early age and so
when you left Harvard where'd you go I
went to Washington to work at the
Washington Monthly to continue the story
I worked at the Washington Monthly for
two years I went to Texas and worked for
Texas Monthly for a while as a writer
came back to Washington worked for the
post experiences that I was just talking
about I then went back to Texas Monthly
again as executive editor and did that
for a while then I decided I really
wanted to be a writer and not an editor
and went to work for the Atlantic
Monthly as national correspondent in
1983 which is what I still do let me ask
you about both the Texas Monthly and the
Atlantic Monthly what is it about those
publications that draw a writer to them
number one there are among the very few
magazines that have staff writers
aside from news magazine sort of feature
magazines with staff writers if you're a
magazine writer staff writer jobs are
coveted because you can get the time to
really report a story if you are a
freelancer which most writers for
feature magazines have to be you know
the clock is always ticking every
additional day of reporting you do on a
story is costing you money so there's a
tremendous temptation to be sort of
superficial and and and so I really
wanted to go to a place where there was
a commitment to serious reporting in
longer magazine articles and where they
would put you on staff so you could
really devote the time and Texas Monthly
I don't know if you're familiar with it
it's really the best city or regional
magazine in the country and has been for
some time it's a distinguished magazine
not well known outside of Texas
and also I love Texas it's a wonderful
story the other thing as you can see
from the book I I noticed early on that
I was different for most of my fellow
journalists in that I was more
interested in writing about sort of what
I would call American life then I was
right in writing about presidential
politics in other words mostly young
reporters I started out with we're sort
of pointing toward getting on the White
House beat or the presidential campaign
beat and and I just was never that
interested in that and always wanted to
write about American life things that I
think are important but are not defined
as news and that's what sort of took me
to Texas away from Washington okay so
you went to the Atlantic Monthly and
you're still there right how many books
have you written three last one was
before it was out of the forties the one
about that looking at the people in the
old pictures you did the Philadelphia
series mm-hmm didn't quite like so you
wanted to go on and find somebody else
to write about or you needed that we're
going back to Ruby right Hanes so what
happened was when I was interviewing for
a job at the Atlantic I made it very
clear to the editor Bill Whitworth if
this is what I wanted to do this was the
big project I had mine he was very
interested in it too so so that was
always part of the program for my
working at the Atlantic so we started we
were going to pick a city to write about
and he suggested Chicago which I think
was a very good suggestion
say why if you're writing the story of
this great migration Chicago is sort of
the its mythic its its its its see if
you write about New York everybody says
well that's just New York you can't you
can't draw national implications from
New York if you write about Washington
Washington is very atypical because it's
a government city Chicago is a big
industrial brawny city and
it has it's during the time of this book
it's really the capital of black America
the south side is probably the biggest
contiguous black neighborhood in America
was then and probably is now south side
of Chicago South Side Chicago how many
blacks live there
well Chicago has three million people
forty percent are black tell me how many
that is you could have met just a how
did almost 2 million now a million 1% of
3 million would be 1 point okay
1.2 million black Chicagoans of those
close to a million would live on the
south side what's the south side of
Chicago like it's huge it has a lot of
different kind of neighborhoods that's
one key to understanding it it's it it
is not repeat not just the slums it has
some of the worst slums in America it
has the biggest high-rise public housing
project in the world which is the
setting for much of my book the Robert
Taylor homes
it has also vast huge sort of middle
class to upper middle-class black
neighborhoods so it has the whole gamut
of experience on the south side really
it's a it's a very very place for those
who have seen your book yet you start in
Clarksdale huh you go to Chicago huh
then you spend a lot of time in
Washington back to Chicago mm-hmm back
to Clarksdale right there's a five
different section of the book right so
Atlanta hide what's the reason for that
well I I wanted I like the symmetry of
the arrangement for one thing it's sort
of like if you go to the symphony they
have the overture and then they have the
coda and they're sort of the same so I
wanted to have have that aspect in the
book it opens and closes in a circle or
sort of it opens and closes in the same
place the Washington section I could
leave Clarksdale also because I thought
people would want to know after I start
in Clarksdale people would want to know
well what happened to Clarksdale how did
it turn out there
you've left Clarksdale in 1948 or
whatever and it's just it sort of
dropped off the map and there's a lot of
interesting stories about Clarksdale
civil rights movements effect there and
the war on poverty there which was sort
of a success story
unlike Chicago big name that popped out
at me I suppose it's my generation was
Muddy Waters Muddy Waters is from
Clarksdale was from Clarksdale know a
lot no he died recently he died well not
he died about eight years ago he grew up
on a plantation outside Clarke still
called the Stovall plantation that's one
reason why I chose Clarksdale I said why
I chose Chicago
I chose Clarksdale because muddy waters
two things Muddy Waters is from there
and the mechanical cotton picker was
invented there okay but for those who've
never heard of Muddy Waters who was he
he was the great the king of the blues
I think certainly he was without
argument the king of the Chicago blues
he was one the leading member of this
generation of Mississippi Delta blues
people who were born and grew up in the
Delta moved to Chicago as part of the
black migration and changed their sound
once they got there by using electric
guitars and drums to produce the you
know so-called electric electrified
blues sound so he and his generation
invented that sound the Chicago blues
and what am i right you said you've been
working on it for six years you started
working on this in this book in 1985 84
84 it's my fault but let's go back again
and try to find out how you found Ruby
Lee hot okay I'm getting to the annual
slice hangs that that happened that
happened later I was a picture cago and
and let me just also say about Chicago
some other things that are attracted me
to it was the
that the Muslims were headquartered
there many you know sort of famous black
organizations were there and now evany
magazine Johnson publishing company is
there then the Chicago Defender leading
black newspaper in the country was there
that was run by a future congressman
Dawson was the he Runner the defender
note the defender was run by Robert
Abbott
and then later by Abbott's nephew John
sing stack sinks tax papers but Bill
Dawson was a congressman from right he
was he was the great now forgotten but
he's a fascinating figure he was the
black boss of Chicago really for 30
years the most of the period in this
book 1940 when he was elected to
Congress until his death in 1970 he
ruled politics of black Chicago Elijah
Muhammad Joe Lewis lived in Chicago
Mahalia Jackson lived in Chicago Dawson
who was a powerful political bus mayor
Daly who's a wonderful character to
write about all of these were
attractions of Chicago first black
cabinet officer in any presidential
cabinet Robert Weaver who is still
living although he's ill was living in
Chicago I sort of felt like everybody
was in Chicago then he was living in
Chicago then Louie Martin who was was
one of the leading civil rights advisors
to presidents Kennedy and Johnson he was
a protege of Robert Abbott of the
defender and and lived in Chicago and
then ran a paper for Abbott Detroit and
then another whole side of it is the
University of Chicago sociology
department out of which came every
theory and every intellectual trend
having to do with ghettos so that's
another point about Chicago but anyway
um Clarksdale had muddy waters
these huge cotton plantations and the
cotton pickin machine the way I found
mrs. Haynes was finally after many many
many blind alleys I needed somebody who
was from Clarksdale who lived as a
sharecropper who had moved
Chicago and I really wanted somebody who
had lived in high-rise public housing in
Chicago because that's part of this
whole story is how that housing was
built and how it declined so you had to
have been through the Stations of the
Cross to qualify for my book you know
and and and then also not only did you
have to live through all this stuff but
you had to be a very extraordinary
person with an unusual memory and
unusual storytelling ability so in other
words a lot of people qualified but but
they couldn't remember it all she has an
unbelievable memory she's one of these
people who can remember you know every
phone number of every place she ever
lived every rent check and how big it
was dollar amounts of everything
everyone's name she can recreate each
scene in her life playing all the parts
she's amazing anyway the way I found her
finally was after some moments of
despair that I would never find somebody
like this
by building privately and managing for
HUD subsidized housing projects and by
the way they're excellent projects and
he is rather he's viewed he's
interesting because he's viewed as many
people like that are in the white
community has a kind of a poverty pimp
but he's beloved in the black community
because he runs good projects he knows
everybody who lives there he lives in
the same neighborhood where his projects
are he goes to church with Ruby Haynes
and so on so anyway he got interested in
my project and put out the word to the
managers of his projects to help me
locate migrants so I would go around to
the various housing projects in
Clarksdale meet with these managers and
they would put me in touch with people
who had made this great migration or new
people who had or Atkin folks who had
and in doing that several rounds of
interviews finally I met mrs. Haynes how
many people did you interview to get to
mrs. Haines I don't know it's hard to
say I haven't counted it up I'd say a
hundred but maybe it's hard to say
because I was doing this for so many
years and I was doing you know several
hundred interviews for the book as a
whole I interviewed a lot of other
people besides just migrants but
counting everybody that I that I you
know sort of tried out for the part one
hundred sounds about right where'd you
find her you mean where in when the firt
when you met her for the first time did
you know immediately no I did I was too
dumb I mean she knew and I didn't that
was the irony of it by the way why isn't
there a picture of her in the book I
don't really know why I'm as you can
tell a photography buff and I always
wanted to have photographs in the book
and my publisher bless their hearts
their grade publisher has never agreed
with me that there was a need to have
photographs bound into the book of the
people there's not only mrs. Haynes but
there's several other people whose life
stories I tell in the
and I sort of had in mind they let us
now praise famous men way that you would
get a really good photographer who would
take these people's pictures and I could
never sell the publisher on it but there
was a wonderful picture of mrs. Haynes
that appeared in the New York Times
Magazine which we're in an excerpt from
the book and photographer Magnum
photographer and Eli Reed took a
terrific picture of her but it's not in
the book anyway where were we we were
starting to talk about Ruby Lee Hopkins
she's okay how old how old is she she's
75 what happened was as I say there was
many many starts and stops and blind
alleys and looking for characters that
when I met her I had gotten to a certain
point in the research when I decided I
would go back and forth I would say I'm
going to find this person in Chicago I
would say to myself and then I'd say now
I'm going to find this person to
Clarksdale so I was in one of the phases
when I thought I'm going to find this
person in Chicago so I put out the call
to these managers mr. Gordon's managers
saying I'm looking for people living in
these projects who close to who have
kinfolk living in public housing in
Chicago I want names of people now
living in public housing in Chicago with
Mississippi roots by the way it's
impossible to find those people in
Chicago because all of officialdom has
sort of written off the projects so you
would think oh there must be some social
worker or somebody who knows everybody
in the projects but in fact nobody does
they have very little contact with the
outside world
Chicago government has written off the
public housing projects until recently
when a very good man named Vincent Lane
became director of the Chicago Housing
Authority and he has sort of sold me on
the idea that he it for the first time
in decades is a really sincere dedicated
director of the CH a how many people in
Chicago live in public housing there's
an official number in an unofficial
number the official number is in fact
there's a lot of different numbers
something over a hundred thousand people
though some people think as much as
250,000 people who pays for that
well some are being paid for and some
are it but but primarily the federal
government deliver it cost you nothing
no you pay a rent you pay but it's a
very low rent and the rest is picked up
by a federal subsidy I say people don't
know because officially the population
of these projects is almost completely
women and children unofficially there's
a lot of men living there but they're
not they're not official residence and
they're not paying rent anyway at that
so I got the name of mrs. Haynes as a
person who had a relative living in
Robert Taylor homes in Chicago that that
being her daughter-in-law connie daniels
whose life story i also tell in the book
and she's still living in the webber
tillers so i called her just to get her
daughter-in-laws name address and phone
number
I met her daughter-in-law before I met
her and when I called her she said
something along the lines of done she
went to interview me so I thought well
sure I do want to interview you next
time I'm down in Mississippi I'd like to
I'll call you so I did and I interviewed
her but it was the end of a long day I'd
interviewed people all day long and
half-hour increments again I was sort of
like a casting director in terms of
looking for the right person to write
about and you know you see those scenes
in the movies where they're auditioning
hundreds of people for a part and you
wonder how can they really know that
they're getting the right person so I
interviewed her at the end of the day I
asked a lot of questions designed to see
if she fit the first qualification that
is the Stations of the Cross
qualification had she been in all these
places and and so I was saying when did
you where did you live then where did
you move then where did you move then
and then what happened then what
happened then what happened
fine and then I at some point had
occasion to call her back I had
meanwhile begun interviewing her
daughter and
quite a bit in Chicago and when I called
her back she said you know when you
interviewed me you really did not do a
very good job you you didn't ask me the
right questions the questions you asked
me were dull he is just where did you
move there when did you move there I
have some interesting stories to tell
I've had an interesting life you should
come back and talk to me again so I
thought thank you mrs. Ames and I've
obviously missed something and I went
back there again and I essentially just
said you know okay I'm not going to ask
you any more dumb questions you talk and
and she did and and that was it by the
way what would you rather be doing
asking the questions or having me ask
you I would rather be asking the
questions that's what I've been doing my
whole life and I love it and are you a
little hoarse from all this talking
yeah I've started to God is punishing me
for answering the questions instead of
asking with tell us a little bit about
her but 75 years old we know she now
lives in Clarksdale Mississippi how many
times was she married hmm she was only
married once however she's had various
see she comes from a world in which
nobody ever got married or very it was
very rare for people to get married
there was a tradition of common-law
marriage that's really what she grew up
with in which people would either get
married or not have a marriage ceremony
and move in together
this is a time when you know in the
1930s when the only people cohabiting in
America were poor rural black folks as
opposed to now when everybody is so it
was sort of an unusual habit at the time
but very pervasive in her world I mean
how many children does she have she's
had eight children and so several of the
children well actually only one of the
children was born in wedlock of the
eight
although the let the younger four were
all the father was her husband she's
been married twice her ultimate husband
Luther Haines
but but several of her children were
that were the product of these sort of
shorter lived common-law marriages of a
kind that again were very very common in
the world she grew up with with the rule
in the world she grew up with and and
and became also the rule in in the
Chicago ghetto as there now what do you
most remember from how long did you talk
to her Oh a lot I still talk to her
fairly often I talk to her just a few
days ago
is she a happy one I wouldn't say she's
real happy but she's happier now I would
say she's found a degree of contentment
she talks very vividly about being
happier now than she's ever been before
in her life why one is she's on Social
Security as opposed to being on and off
welfare which she was for much of her
adult life Social Security system pays a
whole lot better than the welfare system
so she's financially much more secure
than she had been before she's living
back in Clarksdale which she really
likes she became for reasons described
in the book quite bitter about Chicago
and really felt that it had let her down
and it hadn't turned out the way she had
hoped it would um and then the other
thing is like many of her friends you
know poor black women she's had many
many problems with men and and she can
talk to you for hours about no good men
and and so when she got to an age when
she just didn't try to date anymore and
didn't try to meet men
she says she became much happier because
because all of her she feels now that
all of her romances in her life always
sort of went awry and left a bad taste
in her mouth which government figure
that you studied and I know there are a
lot of names in here from London Johnson
and the Nixon administration and Sargent
Shriver and Frank mankiewicz
bill moyers and Honda and go on daniel
patrick moynihan i want to ask you about
which government figure in your opinion
did the most to help her life get better
Johnson
without question I mean not just her
there's there's I should again say she's
in a way she's not a typical migrant
although she's had this very dramatic
story because most of the migrants did
not come from sharecropper backgrounds
and most of the migrants wound up sort
of successfully middle-class in the
north there's a character in the book
named George Hicks who would be much
more typical of the migration although
he's had a less dramatic life by virtue
of the fact that he is middle class and
he ironically wound up on the other side
of the housing project equation from
mrs. Haines his he made a career as a
housing project manager he was actually
four time manager of the project where
she lived he wound up you know happy
homeowner he's just retired wonderful
family two cars in the garage and all
that stuff um is he typical he's much
more typical right so his life got
better once he left Clarksdale much
moved to Chicago why'd he stay there yes
he stayed in Chicago he goes back to
Clarksdale a lot he's the president of
every little town in Mississippi has a
club in club in Chicago he's president
of the Clarksdale in Club of Chicago he
goes back to Clarksdale every year they
have a big dinner dance at the
auditorium that they weren't allowed to
go in when they were growing up anyway
he would be more typical and I bring him
in now because I think clearly Lyndon
Johnson did the most for people in the
great migration or for black America in
general it's easier to point to what he
did for George Hicks than it is to point
to what he did for mrs. Haynes although
he did things for both mrs. Haynes his
grandchildren are all in head start a
program that Lyndon Johnson started her
you know basic benefit on
on Social Security is higher thanks to
Lyndon Johnson and succeeding presidents
if she gets sick she's taken care of
through Medicare and Medicaid a Lyndon
Johnson program some of her
grandchildren I think are going to end
up going to college
the grants they get will probably be
grants that were instituted by Lyndon
Johnson the reason that she can go into
any place in Clarksdale if she gets sick
she can go to Clarksdale Hospital the
reason she doesn't have to ride on the
back of the bus anymore and the reason
she can vote is because the Civil Rights
Act of 1964 passed by obj Voting Rights
Act of 1965 passed by LBJ to some extent
you can argue that George Hicks lives
where he lives today because the Fair
Housing Act of 68 passed by LBJ I think
there is no question there isn't anyone
closed there isn't any second place that
LBJ did the most of for black America in
the panoply of white American
politicians in your book on page 115 you
write during his presidency Kennedy's
support for civil rights always came as
the result of the black movements
prodding him into action mm-hmm is that
something you knew before you start this
book not really you know that they were
talking about John F Kennedy on all
these kinds of issues the record of
Robert Kennedy is better than that of
John Kennedy there's been a lot of kind
of ex post facto myth making about John
F Kennedy and civil rights myth making
by the Kennedy circle and and especially
Arthur Schlesinger I would say acting
out of sincere admiration they have kind
of remade him in death into a civil
rights president now he did super
propose the Civil Rights Act although
the consensus is he would never have
been able to pass it he did various
things but on the whole first of all he
just didn't get that race was a great
kind of moral issue in America until
very late if he got it at all
he the why he was very worried about the
march on Washington in 63 would have
preferred that it not happened he was
not thrilled about all the civil rights
activity that dr. King was doing in the
South was always urging him go slower
take time I just he wasn't a crusader on
this issue
Johnson you can question his motives but
he did decide for whatever reason Robert
Kennedy did too both after the
assassination they were going to become
Crusaders on this issue page 177 today
the Moynihan report stands is probably
the most refuted document in American
history though of course its dire
predictions about the poor black family
all came true mm-hmm what's that all
about the morning hen report 1965 a
government report called the Negro
family a case for national action
written by now senator then assistant
secretary of labor daniel patrick
moynihan the morning hen report was
incredibly controversial you know most
government reports are totally ignored
this was a report that said the black
family is falling apart essentially and
said it in very dramatic one might even
say overdramatize terms and it produced
a furious reaction in the then just just
a borning black power movement and in
the kind of academic intellectual left
which was also just coming into being at
the time it won hands assertion made
quite casually and off-the-cuff in the
report in a paragraph that slavery had
destroyed the black family led to a
whole shelf of books by historians
written between 65 and about 1980
proving that slavery didn't destroy the
black family so that's why I say it was
it's an incredibly refuted
the real link between he's Moynihan and
Nixon the obsession they shared was a
deep dislike of the left liberal
political culture that had grown so
dramatically in the past three or four
years and reached its height of
influence during Nixon's first years in
office okay
Moynihan as I just said was just wildly
attacked after the Moynihan report came
out he was pilloried it wasn't just that
these books came out he was booed and
hissed he was called every name in the
book there was really a huge reaction to
this report and and and not a measured
reaction either was not polite debate
there was you know this was a very angry
time in America to 1965-66 and as a
result Moynihan became very bitter and
he became kind of obsessed with the
danger posed to America by these forces
that had gone after his report namely
the kind of interlocking Directorate of
the Black Power movement and the
academic intellectual left so it's my
contention that really the main thing on
his mind in his service in the first
couple years in the Nixon administration
was how can we neutralize and how can we
refute this tremendously destructive and
dangerous force in American life that
was what was really on his mind then and
of course
Nixon hated the same people Moynihan
hated that was one of the great things
they had in common well at this stage in
the game assess senator Moynihan's
influence because he's all throughout
your book and all the different
administration's all the way back to
President Kennedy he was around for this
whole time I mean if you ask the
question there there isn't an official
position of the kind of about to
describe but let's say there was a
position called you know government
Minister chief white person in charge of
responding to the great black migration
who held that job DP Moynihan held it he
was in
thinking about these issues in a
position of high influence all through
the 1960s and in the early 70s and he
was the only person who was influential
in the Kennedy and Johnson
administration's who was also
influential in fact he was even more
influential in the Nixon administration
so he it was all sort of on his watch in
a way I would assess him in this way
he's he's a vet he's a wonderful
character to write about because he's
very complicated he if you judge
Moynihan gets a great press now in part
just because he was there then and and
was was warning about the ghettos and
about bad conditions there journalists
love more Nahan because he is a
journalist in a way he expresses himself
through writing and he he's very verbal
and he just thinks in terms of concepts
you can't fault Moynihan as a sort of a
journalist or intellectual but you can
fault him as a politician in other words
the job of a government official is
presumably to get things done and that's
what Moynihan then was not very good at
and I still think is not all that good
at and and and he really in 88 he
finally passed his first major piece of
legislation but you know his talent he's
valuable I mean he's my senator and I
vote for him but his talent is the
talent of a journalist identifying
issues highlighting issues dramatically
his talent is not getting the bill
passed getting the program set up the
things that Johnson was so good at
Moynihan is not good at so I think if
you ask your earlier question about
Moynihan that what Johnson felt was the
only question that you should really ask
about a politician what he says
doesn't matter what he said doesn't
matter what a politician said I'm giving
you Johnson's view of the world matters
what he did what did he do not that much
he wrote a report he put
a sensational report he proposed a
sensational revision of the welfare
system that failed the record is more of
poses struck and things pointed out than
of achievement how do you feel about
this book how did he you know how do you
feel about this about my book yeah I
like it and I'm proud of is it your
favorite yeah definitely
is it getting the kind of attention you
hoped it would get yes and more more
than I hope too is there anything about
the attention you're getting you don't
like now really no I've really been very
pleased with the reaction to the book
the magnitude of the reaction the kind
of reaction and what do you want the
impact to be well what of what I've
liked about it is I feel that a function
that books can perform I mean all of the
tests that I just proposed to you about
getting things done doesn't apply to me
because I'm not a politician I'm a book
writer it seems to me that the one
function of book writers is just to
write a book that has literary merit and
I'm interested in that but but the sort
of social function and political
function of a book writer is to get
people talking about something just to
kind of gin up the conversation in
America about a subject and I hope that
that's what this book will do in other
words I felt I feel that on these issues
of ghettos it's on everybody's mind it's
kind of a national obsession not always
stated but it's always hovering in the
background behind discussions of issues
but there isn't a good way to talk about
it everybody's stuck there the same
arguments are being used chasing each
other in circles so my hope is that this
book will sort of create a history of
ghettos that allows people to come
afresh to the discussion and really
start thinking about it again and in
particular I hope that the book will
kind of throw out of court the
now familiar argument that we cannot the
government can't do anything to solve
the problems in the ghettos because we
already tried all that in the war on
poverty and it failed and it made things
worse so therefore the one thing we
can't do is try to do anything have you
given a copy of this to Ruby Haines yeah
sure that as she read it yeah she's read
it I mean she where I gave it to her
before publication
she what did she think I think she
basically likes it she's had several
reactions over the last months you know
in the in the end has read it several
times and I think only finished reading
it in book form so several days ago in
her last reaction last time I talked to
her which was on Monday night she was
feeling very positive about the book and
and said she really liked it she was
getting a lot of nice reactions
I mean her concern and my concern are
really the same in a way when you say
why did I pick her I really wanted to
pick somebody that people who don't know
anything about this world would read
their life story and instead of thinking
the underclass what's that you know it's
a bunch of scary numbers it's people on
the news being hauled off to jail
I don't like it instead they would read
her story and think this is a person I
like and understand not a person who's
perfect but but but there would be a
kind of empathy it would be a feeling oh
that's who we're talking about oh okay
well then let's get down to work and
that has this is one thing this please
me about the reaction the book that has
been the reaction nobody
very often people have reacted to her
life story by saying you know this is
somebody who's had a real tough life and
and who should have had a lot more help
than she had nobody has read and said
this is you know the welfare queen of
Chicago to heck with her how would you
define your own political philosophy
well base
I'm a I've been I worked at The
Washington Monthly and which is the home
of the so-called neoliberal movement and
I guess I'm you know to the extent that
any of us are comfortable with labels
that would be fairly comfortable with
that label how did you get George Will
to say the following on the back flap of
the book Nicholas lemon is America's
best writer about America's most vexing
problem the promised land is comparable
in scale to and even better in execution
than gunner mere dolls an American
dilemma published forty-seven years ago
basically we just sent him the galleys
of the book the thing is the thing about
will is I don't know him never met him I
took his hand once several years ago at
a you know convention where he was a
speaker but that's it he's different
from many conservatives around today
because he's a sort of a big government
conservative and and he believes that
most conservatives would be fairly
hostile and including President Reagan
would be fairly hostile to my calls for
more government social programs but will
is amenable to that kind of thing
because he believes you know one of his
books was called statecraft as Soulcraft
he believes government is the repository
of the soul and conscience of the nation
and if there's a problem government
needs to act to fix it and and he's been
good in terms of a kind of moral
sensitivity to the problems of ghettos
over the years by the way the book
publishers have to pay these guys to
never sit no Henry Hampton says this
beautifully written thought-provoking
and at times controversial work deserves
a wide readership who is Henry Hampton
eyes on the prize did you see that he's
the guy who did eyes on the prize he's a
great documentary film producer he did
eyes on the prize he did eyes on the
prize part two he's now working on
two other very ambitious projects one a
history of the Great Depression and one
history the war on poverty what's next
for Nicholas lemon
I don't know I'm back working at the
Atlantic and and I'm not going to sort
of push to get another book out real
soon I take a long time to do these
things and I imagine it will be several
more years before I've got I definitely
want to do another book and I want it to
be about as I said vaguely American life
but I don't know exactly what and and my
job doing my job for the Atlantic is a
great way to do R&D and look around and
see what's out there to write about so
that's what I'm doing now this is the
book the promised land the great black
migration and how it changed America
Nicholas lemon the author thank you very
much thank you